COUNTRY.
THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE IS A
DISASTER.
I FEAR IT'S ONLY GOING TO GET
WORSE FROM HERE.
JOINING US NOW FROM THE FOX
BUSINESS NETWORK, OUR FRIEND
CHARLES PAYNE IS BACK WITH US.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE OIL FIASCO.
IS IT REALLY GOING TO MAKE
VENEZUELA RICH AGAIN?
WE'RE GOING TO REWARD THIS THUG
TWO BIT DICTATOR?
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE A DEAL WITH
THE IRANIANS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THAT'S IT.
YOU KNOW, AND HERE'S THE CRAZY
THING.
YOU TALK ABOUT ENVIRONMENTALLY
POOR TRACK RECORD OF VENEZUELA
-- THAT'S ALSO SOME REALLY HEAVY
CRUDE.
IT TAKES A LOT OF SOLAR ENERGY
TO REFINE IT.
IT IS SO STUPID, SO DUMB.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE ON ANY
LEVEL FROM A HUMANITARIAN POINT
OF VIEW, FROM AN ECONOMIC POINT
OF VIEW, FROM A GEOPOLITICAL
POINT OF VIEW, FOR THE DEFENSE
OF SAFETY OF AMERICANS AND THE
WORLD IN THE WESTERN HEMISPHERE,
IT DOESN'T CHECK ANY OF THOSE
BOXES.
IN FACT, IT MAKES EVERYONE
SINGLE ONE OF THEM ABSOLUTELY
WORSE.
BY THE WAY, IT'S GOING TO GET A
WHOLE LOT WORSE, SEAN.
THIS CONVERSATION WE'RE HAVING
RIGHT NOW, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
ANOTHER CONVERSATION SIMILAR TO
THIS A YEAR FROM NOW, IN TWO
YEARS FROM NOW, THREE YEARS FROM
NOW BECAUSE THE LACK OF
INVESTMENT IN FOSSIL FUELS IN
THIS COUNTRY IS GOING TO BE
CATACLYSMIC TO US.
THIS WHOLE NOTION THAT WE'RE
GOING TO FLIP A SWITCH, NO PUN
ATTENDED AND BE ON SOLAR AND
WIND IN TWO OR THREE YEARS IS
MIND BOGGLING.
IT'S WRONG.
EVERYONE INVOLVED MUST KNOW IT'S
WRONG.
>> WELL, CHARLES --
>> I'M REMINDED WHAT'S DO THINK
-- YEAH.
GO AHEAD.
>> YOU KNOW, ALL THESE OIL
PRODUCING COUNTRIES HAVE ONE
THING IN COMMON.
THEY'RE FACILITIY -
THEY'R
THEY GOT TO BE LOOKING AT THE
U.S. AND THINKING WE'RE PRETTY
DUMB BECAUSE THEY'RE AS AWARE AS
YOU AND I ARE, THAT IN FACT, WE
HAVE MORE NATURAL RESOURCES THAN
THEY DO.
IF WE EVER BECAME ENERGY
INDEPENDENT AND TAKE IT NOT NEXT
LEVEL, WHICH WILL BE ENERGY
DOMINANCE AND WE PROVIDE ALL OF
WESTERN EUROPE WITH ALL OF THEIR
ENERGY NEEDS, WOULDN'T THAT MAKE
AMERICA RICH ALSO?
>> IT WOULD.
AND IT'S SECURE AND SAFE.
HERE'S THE THING.
IT'S NOT JUST AMERICA, RIGHT?
IN GERMANY -- I USED A SCHEMATIC
IN 1974 WHERE GERMANY PREDICTED
OVERWHELMINGLY ALL OF THEIR
POWER WILL BE COMING FROM
NUCLEAR POWER PLANTS.
OF COURSE, THEY SCRATCHED THAT.
THEY BUILT NATURAL GAS
FACILITIES.
NOW THEY'RE TRYING TO EXPEDITE
THEM.
IT TAKES YEARS TO BUILD THEM.
IT'S THE SUICIDE THAT WE ARE
SEEING BY WESTERN NATIONS --
AGAIN, GENERAL KNEW REFLECTING
TO THIS GREEN UTOPIA, BUT
THEY'RE CRUSHING THE STERNZ.
THE BIG QUESTION MARK IN EUROPE
IS HOW THEY'RE GOING TO KEEP
THEM WARM IN THE WINTER?
HERE'S THE THING.
WE WERE BLESSED.
WE HAVE THIS UNDER OUR FEET AT
THIS VERY MOMENT.
A VERY FEW COUNTRIES HAVE AS
MANY RESERVES AS WE DO, THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE HAVE.
FRACKING IS A TECHNOLOGY
MIRACLE.
FOR ANYONE OUT THERE THAT THUMB
THEIR NOSE OR SUGGEST OIL IS
EVIL.  I GUARANTEE YOU, THEY
DON'T GO WITHOUT AN HOUR USING
AN OIL BIPRODUCTS.
IF YOU THINK YOU'RE GOING TO GET
TO A GREEN UTOPIA, AT LEAST BE
SMART ABOUT IT